this highly provocative missile test was
carried out while china's foreign
minister wang yi was in seoul for talks
with his south korean counterpart with
north korea high on their agenda
of course we all want to contribute to
the peace and stability of the korean
peninsula for example not only north
korea but also other countries are
conducting military actions so we should
have all parties make joint efforts to
region dialogues
this was wang's last stop of a
four-nation tour of east asia as china
looks to counter the increasing
influence of the us in the region and
north korea risks angering beijing with
this latest launch south korea is hoping
china will use its considerable
influence over north korea to bring it
back to the negotiating table but with
each missile launch that seems less
likely and shows even china's control
over its neighbor is limited
north korea has also claimed to have
tested a new type of long-range cruise
missile over the weekend and it comes
after a military parade through the
streets of pyongyang last week facing an
economic crisis from international
sanctions and from the pandemic combined
with food shortages from damaging storms
it seems the show of military muscle is
intended as much of a morale boost at
home as showing the world it is still a
force to be reckoned with and it comes
as south korea develops its own military
hardware on wednesday it successfully
test-fired a ballistic missile from a
submarine becoming only the seventh
country in the world to master the
technology
it also announced advances in
high-powered ballistic and supersonic
cruise missiles as both careers continue
to develop their arsenals rob mcbride al
jazeera seoul